[Music]
akshay kumar
is the only actor on forbes highest paid
actors list
who hasn't ever actually worked in
hollywood
he's a huge deal however in bollywood
starring in over 150 movies over the
past few decades
kumar beat out legends like will smith
jackie chan
and even adam sandler for sixth place on
this year's list
akshay kumar was born in punjab india in
1967.
his family lived modestly but made sure
to splurge on trips to the movie theater
every saturday
as a child he gravitated towards the big
hollywood action movies
bruce lee jackie chan sylvester stallone
and arnold schwarzenegger were all his
childhood idols
and he spent his childhood practicing
karate and taekwondo
moving to thailand to study muay thai
when he was in his teens
once he was 22 he moved to mumbai
teaching martial arts for
dollars a month however he soon found
out that if he modeled he could get paid
four times that amount in three hours
he followed that money pivoting from
modeling to acting for even bigger
paychecks
and by 1992 he landed the lead role in
d'dah
a love story his breakthrough role
happened when he was cast in the musical
thriller kilaudi in 1992
setting the stage for him to become
bollywood's biggest action star
and resident heartthrob india produces
more films than any other country
and kumar really didn't need america's
hollywood money and declined lucrative
offers from producers over decades
he can command deals right at home
earning up to 13 million dollars up
front for films like the upcoming bell
bottom and bukchon pandy
he earns even more when he takes a risk
foregoing salary for a percentage of
revenue
once the gold standard deal for
hollywood's a-list that the u.s studios
have long since abandoned
india is home to 1.35 billion people
under the age of 35
an ideal demographic for streaming
services like amazon
who aggressively wooed kumar for a new
series
it will be kumar's first television
project and is estimated to make him 10
million dollars in earnings
and of his 48.5 million earnings made
between june 2019 and june 2020
approximately 24 million of that came
from endorsements
he reps practically everything
multivitamins
tiles toilet bowl cleaners cars clothing
and snack food
[Music]
it's a good thing he switched careers
though he'd have to teach martial arts
for
61 000 years to make his 48.5 million
dollar paycheck